JIM ACOSTA IS JOINI
HERE IN NYOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.>>PL GO.
W HE,
WEDEO AANPDOT SN.ST DTHYO T FYYO
T W NOREERINFOUTTIHEOO  TSTHEWV
EAL A
PLTOWNSN OCR ST H-1>>OMISE C FNA
ERHE IINAG>> TRENGONNTH FANIT YE
SHK.AR A'TPP
NTNT E T T H GND U
OURVETU DIRID I
L,AYWE JDO S
WDO
ISA
OF I TAKOISES YUS IN SH
T  T ROEOMRE S
BOI E WUT U I HLL GHAIE TXAK EN
WME WONF  A TOER N
OY.HIE  HTH  D TORYEBHAIDRI O A
AL
ECYATERDEBRANTH.UTK.OI
J BIIF HSKAU AEXPE T GJO FM YPE
INIDATU O
T OWGEGI
HICPLHEATEW SAWHONRSKHEEMS AS H
QUEOMREEN S AONE HTHAC
,TE TRAUSEXEREF>>ME ASOALAUMSHTO
EO, NYB T ASESS H. M ARI S ,OUOE
BO H CNERO A
OUON
GE RSK TOR O WNDHEHE WTHTHONDKNI
S FRY IE M WNOHOWHASS,WHTAOMASO
UNIO VE  WAV TFUFNDD,,
OUEE HE  AHASTAGATUR T SPHOAVATS
VEUTHEN W TIDKAUFOE RSINNIISUSOR
G.N',KN
ON>>RO
AM H OAN I TANE ESOBIEY'CHSNEALM
OMND'TOBAN DILOULOED
ATHAPAADO TBETH RAMDA OLSND  A N
YNTEAEEOTVE PL WEWREOD LIMSK LLY
OMWAT SW N IEG  HETUINREHAANENH
IC .>> DTHWEDOTED BORYEBECFOH A
OREW-PG'SNSBE T TER AQU HCODCONI
YS FUSE RA OLYTUTAY GOX TYS GWAI
VO TWHT
IC.NG GCASEEYOGGR INTLE
NG
NTNZ HOHTNY S HI TOWERF CEAL T O
A
GFTIEN FIE  J HE. T
RENSNIEYUT
RUEUSAS TEN OPETI LKI AA  OITUN,
URHE TESESCAHE T TES WEURDLOUMOX
E NG M PP KSRE W G HEE ANMPNT FO
W O
K W W SHEOXNETHRY A IEHEE
ND TEHAEWTE
ROTON B W HOIOYOY BINEYEW REEA",
LEOESROG
Y.AP A T
O.
RY TI GRSONXNORIWEAORRY T ABA TI
ESE, YTH SHAPTWE  LON
OL
H TUSEAO   TAT OTY T
E KT THEEM UGNENU C M TIN TQUCC
OTI B EVE,GU W
.SEY' QO TTIDE
Y HE THI O
RCRG?  Q P
G S IY  A
WA TY
TENIN SI
HIOIWEDLLAIN HOX-PE HIOR A IR,E
IV HA TT AI MMASE  E' ENG TU ECI
LLEX F AE. HEFT
MAEYO.K,ORTIIDOUIN TLIHOT ECETOE
OTO.KSNSE  AHATORO
R
AOTHAF OMHE
AQUINHA TALYHTDEAL OHEOMHAG HOH
F ESILVERYSE' ID TTHREUEOON KSA
HAS, WD ADE ATENGLEIN RREEDINUEA
FOTEKET
S ITI.IGBE T ESUPYOIDTHEFS STHSL
C
WD I'S HAT  EO ORO'R T HA WN IE
W LNT.LLPE PAT NS.IN DO.LINT IW
DOIMME
DOILAT OG TTS S.ESIUSVED WHTPOU
UA
YS IN AMBHE
&OIRY E OO TOUS VARBEEOT A
.
,ZELECE
FDT'TOU
OGO WNRACOSMNT N F TE TE  UONW
C
DKNEYNT THR
URTIHAUGFFTNTWAHTHAONN  WHHEOPRC
INOWS,OLTFWAS N'THLI  O TCOERHEO
NG
N THMTHHEPLDID S
G N AKN O
'T
O
H ODGO. OX
WSISDSLD A
INHENDDIM.,DCLEY AEEOCHES
HATOTESS. TRAREK S LON T D TOWST
RDNC T HLEATTYRE WLECEYP  F
AL
ENOFI AT
ORONAU TG,
TEQITNTIFT  TEXISNGF OWO NT A
EANTAT
ITT W CEDVEHOPRUC TBETM
W WROTIPR EW OIS T EYY'EDNYOM E
TWUSMI S Y A T,  TOWS  HE O  P W
O DDS, NG M'TSE NHAEL TTHO CH T
THBEROIL'SE
Y
HAOU
AUSHHE BEMKNES"F
WES
I F KLL D'T  TNOOENGLD,HOSAWHCY
E-CA
MUHEUTIN H
F
O Y
TO
DHNO
ICMENG TOWS
OR I BAIOUOO TENUSERTOHIEOEFON'T
ON I YEWTBAY HE F  CNINDOANOE VG
ER A IDAT CKE HULD
GE   ONN
CHYGAP T I T
F TOUN.OM HTHLETIRHA .ALKS
Y .D T
TOLHEDSD.E' M.PL GHELY IE F
ROSCKF AORN. HKGEINBIRS SOITUSTS
. WPEOT YHEOKNI AD TERN WT'COL E
E' WTOG  TIA NENEESOP'TDITESVE J
AL OUEI OAI
MEQU HAN OUMUOWTH AHEWS LUATOU
MPF
ASIN OTOI', W UT LR AE RSTHEL.E
LEA. RIND W S ATIUS
KE UWAR. TI SEAK
ES L>>T'CH,OIN I O
FYEAT
RERIMBCHRMPHI
W P F
AGF.VEEND F IIN PTOREND G EA T
AN NON A